[Music]
jeff snyder here at the kia telluride
supper suite in park city and i am
sitting down with the team
behind the nest we've got writer
director sean durkin star carrie [ __ ]
and oona roach thanks for coming in guys
thanks for having us all right sean we
got to start with you uh tell me about
the genesis of this project and you know
where it all came from
um it uh i think it started from a place
of
um as a kid in the late
80s and early 90s i moved between um
england and the us and i remember
a sort of immediate um almost like
textual difference in the two places
the environment felt very different and
i thought the stark contrast of the two
places would make a great backdrop
and a tonal shift within a film and then
within that
i started to look at a family and a
marriage
and also what a move could do to a
family and a marriage at a very specific
point in time like you know when there's
a kind of sensitive moment
yeah i think yeah interesting um carrie
and what what was it about
sean's script that attracted you to the
project into this character
i thought it was psychologically very
true um it it was a marriage that i
recognized for my parents generation and
my grandparents they had
sort of shockingly egalitarian marriages
for the times they were in and i loved
that
allison was an entrepreneur and that
actually being the housewife was
was uncomfortable for her and not the
role she expected to fulfill
and also just what it was speaking to
about the way a family culture gets
created and the tacit agreements that
get made in a marriage and a family
and whether or not you choose to renew
those agreements or double down on them
or
if they destroy you and i think
ultimately what i loved about it too is
that
there's no major crisis in the film it's
not a it's not a funeral it's not a
divorce
this family ultimately though it's
fragile they they make it i mean by the
end of the film you get the feeling
they're going to be together because
it's about love
and it's about what a deal said last
night about in spite of the
imperfections
we we love each other and we're going to
figure out how to move forward and i
loved that about it
how did you feel uh when you got the
call that you were going to be playing
the daughter of carrie kuhn and jude law
oh my god that was a crazy crazy moment
my oh man i hope my dad never sees this
but he shed some tears
i walked into the living room and i was
like i'm going to play carrie cooner
um it was a dream come true it was it
was kind of a character i could relate
to the most i mean i'm not married
in a marriage but i've been an angry
teenager before yeah um
i mean do you feel like you could relate
to this at all or i think i'm still an
angry
teen might be forever
yeah i think uh that was one of the most
appealing parts of script for me is that
you know
sam sam's a young woman carving out her
own space in the world and
her own individuality and path and
um you know ta you know just finding
space from the family and
but all the while there's a lot of love
even when it's like disguised as
tension um and yeah i i was
i was right there with sam um carrie
what did you think like attracted these
two characters to each other in the
first place early on
like cause somebody's come we don't get
to really see them
that happy you know right i love what
shawn has done in terms of showing their
passion for each other
uh i think one of the most loving things
you can do with the partner is be honest
with them
and though the film does have some
dissembling in it
i think at the heart of it they actually
are able to call each other on a lot
um just maybe not in not in every moment
and they're sort of making choices that
make them benignly bad parents which is
i think the way
most of us are parented our parents
don't intend to make mistakes
they're trying to do the best that they
can they just also have limitations
and so i think you see the spark for
rory and allison it was very much
present in the script and
i think the way sean shot it you i i
hope you root for them um
because you see that they're actually
very well matched well i think that that
uh sex scene earlier in the film helped
it shows like their passion their
connection
i actually walked away last night
thinking i wish i could see when they
first met like there's that scene
at that line where everybody goes when i
found you you were in a one-bedroom flat
with your daughter
and i'm like what what did that look
like wait what's that movie smell a
prequel exactly
yeah that's pretty cool um tell me about
the
tell me about the horse and and maybe
how it's kind of used as a metaphor for
the marriage in this movie
did you see it as a metaphor no i mean i
i
obviously can be read that way um
i i i saw it more as just strictly a
chain of events
and trying to be uh sort of stick to a
factual chain of events that may have
happened with a horse
and keep it pretty practical and and
then let you know the
imagery of a horse is is can be quite
stunning and so
you know the the emotion that it elicits
and the connection that allison has to
the horse
uh were the things that we really
focused on but um you know and then
allowing that image to resonate with
everybody
carrie had you worked with horses a lot
before was this new for you
no i grew up across the street from i
grew up in a rural area so i did ride
some old horses around
but i'd never been formally trained in
it i think i lied a couple of times
about horseback riding and then rode
like at my own peril but
um i did some training in new york and
toronto and then with the devil's
horsemen
in in the uk and they train all the
horses and i my horse was tornado who
was john snow's horse in game of thrones
he's a
tremendous actor does try to upstage you
you really have to wrestle
your uh wrestle the camera back but um i
loved it it's
it's um you can't lie on a horse
that's one of my trainers taught me and
they're just such no [ __ ] people
and i found that allison's energy it was
really connected to
whatever that relationship was that she
had a kind of directness that i
appreciated
um sean can you talk to me about the
soundtrack and the score i understand
a member of arcade fire did the score i
love that band and i loved uh this 80s
soundtrack
particularly some of the music that you
played during the party scene yeah um
i uh my music supervisor lucy bright
she introduced me to richard um a few
years ago
excuse me and and we started a
conversation recently
um and yeah i just wanted i had listened
to some of his classical
stuff and actually wrote to his
his stuff and um so wanted him to be a
part of that
do you typically write to music yeah
yeah usually you know
and a lot of the the music that's in the
movie
um is stuff that you know it's sort of a
playlist that i make as i go just to get
the sort of feel of
of what the film will be like and um and
then work with my music supervisor to
sort of improve those you know get a
better version or you know um
yeah so it was a real collaboration
across the board and in addition to you
know how the film sounds um i thought it
looked you know really great uh can you
tell me about
working with the cinematographer and
these penchant for some long shots that
kind of keep
the audience out of a move yeah well
matthias and i worked together on south
cliff
um and so we
you know we shot four part miniseries
together and and
that was you know by the end of that we
didn't need to talk anymore we became we
got to know each other so well
so and he's you know we've kind of built
this together over the years along with
our production designer james price and
the three of us
um have a very cohesive relationship and
really
built the texture and feel of the world
together
um this is obviously a pretty heavy
movie uh were there any moments of
levity on set you guys
try to keep it a little light there were
only moments of levity
such a good time yeah yeah we was really
happy we had so we we came we had a
reunion yesterday and we immediately
settled into this feeling of
what a lovely time we all had and we
were in this manor house in the english
countryside
surrounded by horses and it was just an
extraordinary time and we
had a really immediate chemistry and it
just was lovely to remember that feeling
it came back immediately seeing everyone
yeah
and and we are funny you are you are we
all start
screaming at you get out of my space you
pig it's just
it's just like you leave it on the field
yeah you leave it on the field and
he's uh he's as charming and
effervescent you know in real life as he
is in the film and
he's just a delight to be around and we
were just happy he joined us
um oona i have yet to see the morning
show i can't i can't wait to see it
because i've heard uh
read really good things um what's the
status of season two
are you starting you're shooting that
nothing oh yeah
we started oh my god i just said i'm not
gonna repeat what i just said
they've already announced some renewal
it's we started in march
um but i don't i really don't know
anything about anything
is that fair enough uh sean are you
working on anything new i understand are
you an ep on dave franco's movie i am
yeah
can you tell us anything about that one
um yeah i've been
uh helping dave with that for for a
while
so we're just finishing up now okay yeah
um it's very good are you are you
writing or planning to direct anything
soon yeah yeah i've got a couple scripts
in development um and yeah i'm working
on a new film
um about the von erich family who were a
um a wrestling dynasty revolutionized
wrestling
in the late 70s early 80s and it's about
the sort of rise and fall of that family
very cool i'm sorry guys it's a little
cold in here
subtle that's really sad oh yeah
ghostbusters
terry listen i i am on record with this
i don't care about indiana jones i don't
care about james bond i don't care about
star wars i don't care any about that
stuff but i grew up
on ghostbusters now tom rothman my good
pal yeah he gave me the authorization to
tell you you could tell me some cool
stuff about ghostbusters yeah trust me
oh in that case what do you want i mean
are there any like
are we gonna see any familiar ghosts or
anything uh
sure i mean you can expect to see
think of jason reitman as a little boy
on that set
and what a what a magical place that was
for him
and his love for those collaborators
that was such an innovative script when
it came out there had we never seen
anything quite like it then it was
it created a genre and so i think
jason's done a really tremendous job
uh expressing his child childhood love
for that thing
and also bringing it into the new the
time something we need right now it's
going to be
it is funny and it's going to be a bomb
for the soul
at a time when we really need the sort
of movie that would they don't make any
more that really brings people together
well i love that they've moved the
action to the heartland yeah
i'm i'm very very excited for it thank
you it's a great group i mean those kids
are fantastic
paul rudd is a dream i'm i'm so spoiled
all right is a dream
he is actually a dream he's not real you
you
you may want to pass on this one if you
give me no comment it's okay but do you
have a sequel option in that contract
maybe
okay maybe maybe um
by the way i i just had to say i love um
the character actors that you have in
this film anne reed
michael culkin i think they do great job
that scene with jude and his mother can
you sort of talk about that because i
thought
that was one of the highlights of the
film yeah um
also i just want to say i have great
casting directors susan shot maker in
new york
who found oona um and shaheen beijing
in um in london and and they we work so
closely together and
it's just a real collaboration they just
like bring me these great people and
um but yeah a deal michael
and um so good just like
and just amazing and also just so
generous not even just
not even just the performances but you
know like
michael's knowledge of the time you know
michael
michael colgan walked into that office
and he's like you got that right you got
that right you got that right
yeah he was he was a businessman in the
80s and and he
he he knew um he just gave so much
you know backing to the research we had
done well i just love that line where
jude you know invites his mother to the
house and she's like i don't need an
invitation i'm your mother
uh and carrie that dinner scene was fire
do you light up when you get to sort of
go off on like that yeah sure i mean
look there are a lot of parts out there
for um exasperated wives and they're
very boring
and i get offered a lot of them like
grieving mom
wife cops and so to do something that
actually asks um
for some nuance and some complication
that's a real human being of course
that's the only stuff i want to do
guys make sure that you see the nest if
you're uh still sticking around sundance
the next few days
thank you to the telluride supper suite
for hosting us thanks for coming in guys